una reunión del consejo de seguridad
dominada por la incertidumbre pues se
teme la eventual reanudación de las
hostilidades entre israel y la yihad
islámica a pesar de la tregua negociada
por egipto que entró en vigor el domingo
preocupación planteada por el enviado de
la onu para oriente medio antes de las
conversaciones si el alto el fuego es
frágil
cualquier reanudación de las
hostilidades sólo tendrá consecuencias
devastadoras para los palestinos e
israelíes y ahora en alcanzable el
progreso político y el ejército israelí
presentó su operación lanzada el viernes
en casa como un ataque preventivo contra
la yihad islámica dos de sus principales
jefes militares murieron pero también 44
civiles palestinos entre ellos 15 niños
una situación inaceptable para el
embajador palestino en la onu como
máxima autoridad responsable del
mantenimiento de la paz y la seguridad
internacionales está usted dispuesto a
decir que ya es suficiente y cuántos
años más podrá imponer su inhumano
bloqueo a dos millones de personas la
mitad de ellas niños antes de que
alguien hasta sin embargo según las
autoridades israelíes los ataques
fallidos con cohetes de la yihad
islámica fueron responsables en parte
del elevado número de víctimas
la yihad islámica palestina disparó
deliberadamente 1100 cohetes contra
civiles israelíes unos 200 de los cuales
cayeron en la franja de gaza matando a
palestinos inocentes incluidos niños
pequeños esta es la cruda verdad israel
tiene todas las pruebas en israel es el
doctor en la reunión no se logró ningún
avance importante y tampoco un
comunicado al final de las consultas a
puerta cerrada que iniciaron después del
debate público